hallo mein name ist luca ich weiß ich
sie gar komplett anders aus mir wurde so
aufgeschrieben dass ich wieder zettel
mehr zocken soll und deswegen tue ich
das nun ich geh mal kurz raus aber ich
muss echt heftig kurzen ja z 0 er an
alle die es nicht wissen ist eine
website auf der tatsächlich so was hier
wir kriegen nur scheiße ich dann einfach
mal random drücken und dann das was soll
s darstellen ich kann quasi of random
drücken und dann bekommen wir
verschiedene sachen über spieler die
hier so eine anime tänzerin umbrüche
bekommen wir hier sondern mit anderen
menschen und dann bekommen die wir noch
eine andere frau dann bekommt falls euch
fragt wieso ich so aus hier hat der arzt
gesagt jetzt war ich war krank und war
beim arzt und also ich bin immer noch
krank das hätte wahrscheinlich und der
meinte hat mir so ein paar sachen
empfohlen um ein halbes jahr haben weil
ich meine augen total rot und ich meine
es ehrlich sollte früher meine brille
tragen wenn ich vom pc setzte und dann
dann erst wie oft habe ich jetzt gemacht
ich sie ja eigentlich nie oder der mach
mal wieder ich jetzt gemacht und es ist
lässig hasse brille zu tragen guckt das
ist eben das ist auch so eine scheiß das
sieht aus wie ich sehe aus wie die hast
auch scheißegal bei der nächsten
webseite haben wir irgend so ein anime
karg und dann haben wir jetzt hier
alles klar ich weiß echt nicht so
richtig was sie von ihrer website halten
solltet mal wieder auf random und
verbote was wasser gab es nicht damals
auch ich weiß über gta san andreas gab
es entschied dass autos die räder von so
nach so bekommen haben oder conti auch
übers wasser fahren
ich klicke mal auf next und wir haben
als nächstes ach guck mal dick und doof
oder sonstige klicken sie auf next und
haben als nächstes werde leute dann
nehmen wir haben einen wow ich war okay
es ist ja kein ding aber er war oma hat
er bananen auf dem kopf ich muss ich
überhaupt nichts hinterfragen so die
cape habe ich auch bei meiner haare die
ihr seht schon das ist ein totaler
friedhof irgendwie also ich weiß nicht
was er damit machen soll irgendwie will
ich zum friseur war irgendwie sagen
meine eltern ich soll ich zum friseur
weil die es gut finden aber guckt euch
das an was ist denn nun überlegt
vielleicht bald man so ein hair style
sheets machen wie man harre irgendwie
mal anders machen weil jetzt kann ich
damit eigentlich alles mal ich komme mit
theoretischen zopf machen guckt dann
mache ich so und dann hätte ich hier
einen zopf
ich weiß ja nicht
ich weiß ja nicht wie beauty palace und
mir jeden tag nehmen wir wahr dass die
wer fährt sich inter star irgendwie
anderes mittlerweile verjuxt ihre haare
ich will jungs mit grauen haaren und
denkt wenn du so jung
egal was geht man seit ihr 70 oder ein
pferd als mal wirklich mit auf fremdem
und wir haben als nächstes auch er tritt
ihm in die eier alle er spricht über
einen zaun er sagt auch irgendwas und
dann kommt ein pferd und dann ist noch
ist die tour und er macht wieder
irgendwas und jetzt wichtig immer wieder
fremde hatten wir nicht ob ich verlinke
euch mein altes titel er video hier
kommt das an
ich hab das schon mal gemacht das
kammergericht huber ja nicht weiß gar
nicht warum lässt du die videos durch
guckt sich so die zettel lehrvideos
alles über eine million aufrufe decken
unsere seid ihr behindert videos in
kacke guck mal vernünftige youtuber
wehrmacht gibt's youtuber die
vernünftigen content hochladen guckt
juli m m
der kann was ich bin nicht jeglichen
wieder
random und das nächste was wir haben
dass er die page ist es heuer von dieser
slot blatt kreise wie kriegen wir haben
irgendwas von dragonball als nächstes
haben wir frau die genauso wie wir dich
gott nein das ist etwas geschlagen hier
war toll da will ich das darstellen das
ist man auch hier wieder alles kaputt
steht die auch noch krupp ich werd ja
nicht mehr als vor 10 okay so gut luca
bleibt so stehen
disney ladies face the ace okay ich
glaube wir haben es wichtig wieder auf
next und wie halt dein maul
wir haben hier komischen bunte figürchen
die sich irgendwie tatsächlich alter die
drehen sich alle und sind in alle
richtungen irgendwie alter passiert das
leider noch groß dass sie vorne wird
klein die dringliche jetzt wird wieder
dass sie wird wieder laut fakt ist wenn
einer von euch gerade breit ist oder
sowie die wirkt das erfolgt hier klicken
wieder auf next und haben bei microstrom
es tut mir leid dass ich weiß wie
shoretel stand ich wirklich schreibt es
in die kommentare wie so schaut es ihr
wie sie schaut ihr dass euch das an
gerade ich meine ich gucke es mir selber
guckt mir dabei zu wie ich mir die
website anschauen also das macht doch
keinen und auf der website mit sowas
gezeigt wie ein hut und l'oreal also ich
meine bei allem respekt so fans
wenigstens irgendwas tolles mehr aber
das ist das ist einfach es ist scheiße
also es tut mir leid dass ich so
selbstkritisch mit mir selber bin aber
gott
ist ein spiegelbild von mir hey ich
hoffe dass jetzt einmal bei die nächste
sachen sondern wir jetzt hier bekommen
bekommt eine rein geschlagen haben wir
gott ich dachte weißt nicht was ist soll
diese website
jetzt mal ernsthaft einige treiber
dieser website falls sie dieses video
sehen wieso habt ihr das gemacht als ich
meine warum ich würde an dieser stelle
sagen ich sehe da keinen sinn mehr drin
wieso ich mir das anschaue ich meine
vielleicht ist es für euch witzig wie
ich mich darüber kaputt lache aber ich
bin für meine augen ist es gerade nur so
duca warum sollte ich dieses video
gerade hochladen weil schaue mir sachen
an die ihr euch selber anschauen können
und ich sehe aus wie ihnen spaß
vielleicht hat es euch trotzdem gefallen
wer das getan hat würde ich mich über
eine bewertung von euch freuen schreibt
noch mal die kommentare ob es noch mehr
solcher webseiten wie z er gibt wo ich
vielleicht auch mal darauf reagieren
könnte wo das ganze hat vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr sinn hat und dann sehen
wir uns im nächsten video wieder